Alright, so, we're back with our first viewings, and we're going to do...
-What are we watching?
Viva Rock Vegas.
Yeah, I probably deserved that.
Uh, we haven't seen this, but we've made fun of this a lot.
It's sort of another one of those infamous "Bad Sequels"
But we have not seen it, so...  Maybe it will be good!
Maybe we're just jumping to conclusions!
-No, I...  you know what?  I will...
Just jump the gun?
-I will bet you $10, right now, that we are not...
I am not gonna take you up on that bet!
I don't even like the Flintstones!
I don't even like the cartoon!
I like what it did for TV and everything, and opening up prime-time animation...
- C'mon the cartoon's great!  It's all about abusing poor prehistoric animals by making them do household chores.
That is the only funny part, in the cartoon, I love that part.
-Ehh
Here we go, this is our first review, our first viewing review, or whatever you want to call it, of "Viva Rock Vegas".
Oh Christ!
-Oh shit!
Oh!
-Gazoo?
Oh, no!
Ah!  Ahh!!  Ahh!!  Ahhhh!!!!!
Alan Cumming in his most terrifying role since "Son of the Mask"!
This.  Is.  The stuff of nightmares...
Stephen Baldwin!
(Laughter)
-Like, "Usual Suspects" Stephen Baldwin, or "Slumming it, Pure Flix" Stephen Baldwin?
"C'mon, we're late for God's Club!"
Oh god
So we've had aliens, cavemen, and Las Vegas...
I'm sure all of these are going to connect beautifully.
Who gave this very unfunny MAD TV sketch a lot of money?
-You know, the CGI on that dinosaur is not very impressive.
Actually, the scary thing is, his Rubble's pretty good
I think it was the role he was born it play...
"You passed!"
He'll drop it on him, drop it on him...
Drop it on him...  There you go, okay.
-Wow, actual animatronics!
Yeah, I'm actually thoroughly impressed!
As Wilma?
- Yuuup!
That's a weird choice!
-"Incoming message from the big giant head: You've been miscast!"
She's immediately like: "What am I doing in this role?"
-I think that was the moment she realized: "And I picked the wrong agent."
Look there, he goes, isn't he dreamy?
-Gast-rock
-I'm not gonna sleep tonight.
No...
Honestly, riding that dinosaur roller coaster looks like the most interesting thing in the movie.
I'd much rather do that for an hour and a--
How are they filming it?
-You don't have celluloid in...
I need to know!
"This is gonna be fun, huh?"
It's Sally!
-I know!
It's not Wilma!
-And he just looks like a fat John Lithgow, maybe this is something I don't know...
That was creative, I'll give 'em that, at least...
-Yeah, a blind man gets lucky once.
It's a lost "3rd Rock from the Sun" episode, where she gets a starring role in a Flintstones movie.
Yeah, you know, I'll give it this, there's yet to be a "guy from Dune with business plan that makes no sense to screw him over"... I don't know where it's going yet.
-Doug, that actor has a name.
-It's Kyle Etraties, okay?
Okay
Just over that hill, they're shooting "Breaking Bad".
So her mother is Cruella DeVil?
-Yeah, it looks like it.
-Really?  This only has a 3.5/10 stars on IMDB?
-That seems pretty high!
And that was comedy, apparently.
-The music told me, because it went "Wah, wah".
I'm gonna go United Airlines on your ass!
-Umm, that's a horse dick he put on his plate
Oh, yeah, that's a fish.
-Yeah, glub, glub, glub
"Rock Vegas, eh?"
Ahhh!
-Ahh!  Oh ho ho!
Ho ho...
Oh, and this is definitely a ride at Universal, look at that
You ride the car in, and then Stephen Baldwin is literally there, not animatronic, that's just his work.
"Soon, Wilma will see him for the pathetic, primitive primate he really is."
Ah, now we have the bullshit "guy trying to sabotage", okay, took a while!
-"LeWhore, I'm afraid I've been thinking..."
-So are they, like, floats for the Rose Bowl Parade?  Is that why they're decked out in flowers?  Or...
"I just found out what "calamari" means..."
Rose O'Donnell?
That'd be quite an impressive downgrade, if that's her!
-"Oh, so you don't want me as Betty, but you want me as the octopus."
Well, I don't know where this is going...
Oh!  Now, where, where did that comes from?
I am just shocked that's the route they went with that.
Oh Christ...
-What?
We're doing this?
-No, it's okay!  I was just wiping my hot cream off her breasts!
-Wait, it came out totally wrong!
Now if you'll excuse me, I'm going to the bathroom to use the three seashells...
Really?  We're ripping off "Titanic"?
Of all the scenes to rip off from Titanic, you're ripping off that one
Like, arguably the worst scene in the movie?
-Wouldn't it have been so much more amazing if this movie came out first so we could say "Titanic" ripped off "Viva Rock Vegas"?
"I'm systematically poisoning the dinosaur's water supply.  Their entire species will be extinct!"
That was legitimately funny!
-One of the writers snapped, "Fuck it!  I'm going to have one funny joke!  Just one!"
I gotta be me!
-Oh, look what we have here, all join on this thief, oh hoh hoh hoh...
You look at Alan Cumming, and clearly put weird makeup on him
You look at Stephen Baldwin and it's like, what makeup did they put on him?
No, that's just how he looks.
"Hey, I might be out of a job tomorrow.  Brother's gotta have a little nest egg, ya dig?"
-No, that's getting a little too "Dumbo" for me.
It's amazing how much it just so looks like he's there.
-Yeah, I, I'm really something...
This is the only time where Stephen Baldwin really looks like he's looking at something, cuz this is probably what he sees every day.
-Honestly, I think I would probably rather watch the Geico Caveman Sitcom than this.
Don't say things you can't take back.
-I don't know, I'm...  They're shorter.
Ha hah, ha hah, cuz cuz it looks like it, ah, why'd you give him two...
Oh what heights, we'll hit... On with the show, this is it...
This is not the line of work for you, everyone's getting AIDS and shit!
-And somebody at Pure Flix saw this and said: "You know what, we need him for our Christian movie."
-You know, I'd be driven to Christ after this movie too, not gonna lie!
-Is he a dragonfruit?  What is that?
He looks like... how babies are made, just all the sperm going into the egg.
-Actually, interesting thing, they had a laugh track for this, exactly like the show
-But they couldn't even get people to fake laugh at this.
-Gazoo's like: "And now, I mercifully release you from your torment!"
Shut up, shut up, shut up!
-There's six minutes of credits left, that that many people wanted their name attached to this film.
Well, okay, ultimate question, is it worse than the first one?
I feel like this one had more color to it than the first one.
-The first one... this one had more color to it.  And this is scary, I feel like this one felt shorter.
Yeah.
And it did have that one funny dinosaur line, and I can't think of one laugh in the first "Flintstones" movie.
-Gazoo will haunt my nightmares.
-That's for damn sure.
Yeah, that was so terrifying!
-Oh my god...
This movie's stupid, it's just stupid.
-God!
Dumb movie!
-Oh!  I've got nothing to say.  What do you say to this?
Yeah, just dumb.
-Rotton Tomatoes: 25%
-For the record!  I think Donald Trump  right now is sitting at 36%.
-Donald Trump is doing better than this movie
Than Flintstones
-by 11%.
-Well, what can we say but "Ehh, it's a living."
-We'll have a gay old time!
We're done now.  We're done!